foreign
welcome back to Hannity reporting
tonight from Palm Beach and Mar-A-Lago
so I asked president Trump to weigh in
on Biden's policy failures let's take a
look
when you left the presidency gas was a
two dollars and like 20 cents a gallon
you have to go back to the date of the
election as we go back to November 3rd
don't go back to January
it was it was less than two dollars but
during that period it was a dollar 87
and during that period it was also a
dollar fifty we had gasoline I mean it
was incredible what was happening so our
borders were secure gas was cheap energy
was cheap you leave office the Consumer
Price Index the inflation measure is
what 1.4 percent now we're what seven
months in a row at eight point four
percent it's going to be much higher as
soon as the election's over uh they're
artificially I filled up these strategic
reserves when oil was cheap I bought 75
million barrels at a very very cheap
price filled it all up right to the top
first time it happened in 50 years where
it was filled to the top and they've
taken that and they're giving it to
people it's supposed to be meant for war
and for the military they're giving to
people to keep the oil prices down
before an election that's where it's
being used when the election is over
gasoline will go through the roof all
right and so will your heating bills so
will your electric bills the thing about
it I mean what puzzles me and maybe you
can answer it I can't figure it out for
myself but okay we have more energy
resources hundreds and hundreds of years
of natural gas and oil and coal in this
country you've made you got us to energy
Independence that was the first time in
75 years you left office we were a net
exporter of energy right I would argue
especially in light of Putin cutting off
Western Europe that we should be use the
word dominant we should be energy
dominant in providing Western Europe
with their energy needs we were soon
going to be dominant we would have been
the most dominant in the world we would
have been surprised to Europe we would
have been supplying China we would have
been supplying every with 500 years
right under our feet yeah okay so
Western Europe makes a mistake that I
think we're about to make and that is
they gave into the climate alarmists
religious cult I call it right and they
became dependent on Vladimir Putin
hostile actor hostile regime you knew
him well and as a result Germany was
announced yesterday in Italy so
dependent
174 increase in their heating bills
anticipated this year which I said would
happen 30 percent of people's yearly
income will go to heat people's homes
there are real reports and fear that
people will die and freeze to death in
Europe this winter because Putin has cut
them off it's true so we have all these
resources let's explain this to me why
is it okay to get oil from Iran Biden's
trying to make a deal and by the way
last year when nobody was looking he
imported a million barrels 674 million
from Russia last year uh he's been
begging OPEC to increase production they
reject him every time the Saudis have
rejected them he sent an emissary to
Venezuela why would we ever make those
countries wealthy and rely on them for
the lifeblood of our economy especially
in light of what we've seen in Western
Europe because their dependency problem
is now destroying their economies so
listen to it's sort of
it's not to me it's not complex we are
making Putin rich as he does his War
thing he's making money over and above
because it's so expensive barrels of oil
right now
if we have a reduced oil he's going to
have to stop you don't even have to
negotiate the deal would have never
happened that that horrible War where
hundreds of thousands of people
probably are dead already but you
believe it would have happened if you
were president you told me that I know
it wouldn't have happened tell me why I
used to talk to him about it because he
knew that I was going to take tremendous
retribution or he felt that way whether
it's ten percent or five percent did you
tell him in no uncertain terms you would
uh I'd rather not say but the answer is
yes hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else